good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy wednesday
hope everyone's having an amazing hump
day i am because it's sunday and i'm
here and you're here yay
okay jackie's back in studio mom to
haroldson
exclusive interview we've kind of been
killing these exclusive interviews
lately so like this just makes sense in
just a lineup of amazing interviews that
i get to sit down with you thank you so
much for putting me in that category
i've been immensely enjoying the toast
you're crushing it as always yesterday's
episode was very very good and enjoyable
and it's just it's a pleasure it's a
pleasure you said that wrong um how are
you doing like how's life how's
haroldson how are the nipples like give
us the rundown i'll start with the good
the nipples are good
um i'm very very tired last night was a
rough night yeah probably the roughest
i've had in like
months wow and it's only been two months
right exactly like it was like first
week vibes crying crying and i just like
couldn't get like short intervals of
sleep and i couldn't fall back asleep
which is they don't tell you about that
the worst they don't tell you about the
time spent trying to fall asleep right
and it's like sometimes you don't get
any time and then you do get time and
you can't sleep it's so much pressure to
fall asleep and it wasn't it didn't
happen for me last night this morning
when i was getting ready like i felt
like how i used to feel in college when
i pulled an all-nighter like a little
like on the yeah yeah yeah drinking
coffee short circuiting like having
energy that's coming from weird places
you know um so that was a fun throwback
but i'm excited to be here it's nice to
you know leave the house and do the show
and we haven't done a show since kind of
like the episode heard around the world
which one was a friday
friday's episode um was literally like
life-changing first of all um i just
kind of love remote podcasting i can't
explain i think we're just like a little
bit more unhinged than usual yeah
because we're feeling comfortable we're
so like polished here like look at us
literally perfection perfection like in
our sweats we're so elegant elegant
elevated and unique
which which unique now that i am a
toaster i have a running list of things
that you say
so much okay what are they unique yep
twisted yeah
hella mm-hmm i called you after that the
other day yeah i was just wondering if
you're and it was hella rude you're a
surfer on the west coast how about a
dude
um you've also you don't say with me so
much like with other people you use a
lot of more tick-tock lingo especially
if they're tick-tock girls of course one
thing about me is yeah yeah is that a
tic-tac-toe okay um toxic
yeah
and
um
just like girly of course of course of
course well you know whenever i end like
spend a lot of time with brian i end up
saying unique twisted and toxic so much
because that's like we'll have a
conversation it's just like unique
unique twisted toxic yeah toxic unique
and the biggest one what unhinged also a
brian word god you describe everything
as unhinged and i don't think you
realize like it's it's um no but
everything is unhinged jackie look
around that's so true look around that
is true i take it back um we take it
back we have a laundry list of things we
need to talk about and it's two things
and we need to remember both of them the
first start with merch with merch yes so
we haven't had a merch up in a while of
course because you know your girls we're
just busy being business women and
mothers so we have our first merch drop
in a while this friday it's at 10 30 a.m
east 10 a.m eastern time and it is our
spring collection so we are showing off
some of the looks today jackie i'll hsn
you then you hsn me okay move your
camera move my movement your microphone
jackie is wearing our matching other
side our matching sweatshirt and
sweatpants on the sweatshirt it says the
fast life stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast bread emoji and
that same design is on the pants on the
left leg it is a pale pink what size are
you wearing in both items jackie
i believe i'm wearing size medium in
both items and these days i would just
like to say like i used to wear right
now the medium fits me like a small used
to so i'm a true medium i used to just
be like oh i'll have it a little bigger
that's so crazy
snug but not because the clothes changed
i changed and the reason why i cannot
wear that outfit today is because i lost
both items in the caps when my vessel
overturned in the delaware river over
the weekend if you don't know what i'm
talking about listen to monday's episode
i lost and i wore that the whole weekend
it's literally my favorite thing and it
comes with a matching beanie how cute is
that i like work too i work too hard on
my hair to put it on so like do you want
to put it i got my hair cut and blown
out but i'll do it because it matches
this outfit so i'll do it for the
content for the stream also i just want
to say i'm so excited to be launching
this sweat set because we designed it so
long ago so long ago personally had them
for i think a year yeah i've worn it so
many times and so many times was the
only thing i wanted to wear and like i
took a picture and i'm like well it's
not dropping soon so gotta wait got it
the beanie looks so cute on you
so we've got beanies we've got
sweatshirt and sweatpants a cute little
matching set and then we have our
hundred percent collection which we can
just never get enough of we are
launching a crew neck and i have to hsn
oh sorry okay go we are launching a
crewneck of this new hundred percent
design it's 100
spelled out in bubble letters in the
shape of a heart it is so cute it comes
in this blue and white as claudia is
modeling and she's doing a beautiful job
at that it also comes in a white crew
neck with a green design yes and a
matching phone case which is so cute and
we don't have it here but a mug also of
course we love a mug we love mugs and
it's a big juicy mug no none of that
little little mug i just put this phone
case on last week and it's just like
brightened up everything right here
i'm loving this color so it's a very
pleating collection per usual pretty
much expect nothing less and it's just
really cute stuff to help you spring
into spring and then the second list and
so that's friday shopmorningchokes.com
at 10 a.m eastern time yes um we'll have
pictures of all of the items up on our
instagram so you can you know
browse before you shop
and yeah very exciting first drop in a
really long time we hope you guys like
what we made all i've been wearing me
too new merch is all that fits me right
now
same and i don't even have a baby so
um next thing on our item is kind of a
controversial topic but it's something
jackie brought up and i've been thinking
about and
you had been thinking about it well i
had it now i have but like it's come up
in my mind a few times um and that is
you know we got into a habit of opening
this show of course with
good morning millennials it's uh if
you've been watching our show since the
very very first episode it is a joke
from the very first episode of course
we're not directly speaking to
millennials only if you're not a
millennial you can still watch his show
and we say it every day we don't really
think about it but i was just thinking
about it breaking down the words good
morning millennials and
i have a lot of uncertainty around it
now like it was
and i'm not saying it's going to change
necessarily and we want to hear from you
we want to hear from everyone but the
thing is like what if someone's
listening for the first time and they
turn it on and they're like good morning
millennials who are these losers goodbye
yeah no it's definitely like an inside
joke thing and that definitely makes us
look like losers
so i would propose and i think we really
need to talk about it i'm not even
saying this is what i would vote for but
the proposal would be like good morning
blank could be toasters you suggested
girlies i think personally girlies is a
phase so i wouldn't tie ourselves to it
and it's not really an inclusive term
like lest we not forget about all of our
male toys twisters
our male toasters like let's not forget
about all six of them what about good
morning twisters love and then in two
years from now we'll be like we've been
thinking it's a joke from two years ago
i don't know i like good morning girly
girls
yeah but again it could be trendy not
we're more classic than that our classic
so maybe it's good morning toasters it's
just a really big thing to change
and i i feel like maybe it'll be that
thing it's like samson cutting off his
hair i know and the rest is downhill
from here our views just start dropping
and dropping like maybe we should just
stick to the status quo
if you wanna be cool follow one simple
rule don't mess with the no no no
yeah stick to the status quo
whoa
octave change no no no
no stick to the stuff you know
if you wanna be cool follow one simple
rule don't mess with the flow no no
stick to the status quo
that is an iconic octave change what do
you think is the most iconic octave
change in music history because i
already know my answer okay you
obviously have planned your answer
to more than i can be
violins here we go
to
you raise me up
so i can stand on mount sip that's my
in my opinion the best octave change in
music history well you know i've been
listening to a little bit of different
music these days and there's a version
of old macdonald
where at the end i can imagine
they're at the end there's like you know
oink oink here oh i'm going there and
like it's the longest song it's like
keeps going and then at the end to bring
it all together it's oh macdonald had a
farm e-i-e-i-o
it's really beautiful i got an octave
change no it sounds stiff if you listen
to the version
just search oh mcdonald's spotify the
first one that comes up like at the end
they really like bring they bring it
it's my favorite part sounds stunning
yeah the big finish you can tell like
she was in the studio she's like you
mind if i just try a little bit
[Laughter]
i mean literally you having a child has
made me realize like what i was born to
do on this earth is like to be the voice
of children's music like fisher price
like the toys that like play all the
songs like i could sing those losers
like so much better than them yeah the
losers being the singers or the babies
both
no i could sing like i could sing so
much better than the losers already
pre-recorded on all the kids toys like
they have no heart they have no bravado
no no vibrato they have no verve unique
talent or energy
charisma uniqueness nerve and talent and
if you ever want to remember it i just
realized they always say it
c-unt they always hit on drag race oh
also drag race finale
kind of crazy so spoiler alert even
though it's been a week
willow pill won and
she was really strong like really strong
the whole time but like
i don't know
meh justice for lady camden honestly and
i honestly shook bosco to make it to the
top too even though i didn't think she
should win jesus for lady camden and
remember how i said like when we first
started watching like there's no need to
continue cornbread is winning do you
remember me saying that i don't think
you said that yeah i did i said
cornbread as well you said that you
liked cornbread but then you also said
whoever you like doesn't win well then
cornbread went home the next week with a
broken ankle
um but when the when willow pill won
she's like i'd like to thank cornbread's
angle
so i don't think i was wrong about like
really
having an eye on cornbread yeah that's
really funny yeah so that's your drag
race recap and let us know what you
think about good morning millennials
because we're
we're at a crossroads and two roads
diverged in yellow wood and you know
what we don't have to make any rash
decisions this is something that we can
all mull over but i do think it's time
to start talking about it because what
about the new listeners
i agree like and i don't want to
encourage people to go back and listen
to the first episode oh we could tell
you the story no to find it because the
first episode is
horrendous
twisted
it's dare i say unhinged
it's so bad do not listen to the story
is one of my favorites so let me take
you back to 2018 when we were rebranding
our show trying to come up with a name
uh we obviously landed on the morning
toes but along the way you know we'd
like to be like the millennial morning
show so we were thinking like good
morning millennials like good morning
america right
and ben heard us talking about this and
he was like good morning millennials
sounds like if aliens came down to earth
and they were trying to blend in so they
were like
good morning millennials and we thought
it was so [ __ ] funny
and we just kept like adapting it and it
literally very quickly became our
tagline and that's why we say it like
that really because we're aliens just
trying to assimilate
[Music]
aliens trying to assimilate that's so us
um so let us know we want your thoughts
and prayers obviously so you can comment
on the youtube stream leave a comment on
our instagram if you have any
suggestions for good little intros um or
if you you know me i'm very change
averse so if you don't want us to change
it that is a valid response as well yeah
agreed so we had we got our two things
we had two things to talk about we got a
merch good morning millennials yes so
today's show here's how it's gonna go
we're gonna do the fast five obviously
and it's wednesday and we were going to
do deer toasters but we've been slacking
on the um tv recaps of course because
like i said i'm not going to ask people
to like watch tv when they come and
co-host so today we are going to recap
the real houses of new jersey season
finale and the second to last episode of
summer house we'll do a nice big juicy
um tv recap and then deer toasters will
be pushed to tomorrow with taylor's
trekker and she's always really good at
your toaster so i feel good about this
decision yeah i enjoy her deer toasters
she's just lived like a lot of lives i
know and i love hearing about it she's
so funny so
that is tomorrow and friday's episode is
a little bit up in the air in terms of
who's co-hosting we're just gonna figure
it out yeah i don't know if it will be
me i'm gonna try but it might not work
out that's okay we support women here at
the morning toast thank you so much and
we support mothers it's claudia that's
beautiful thank you so much so i think
without further ado unless there's
anything else you want to chat about no
i guess we could jump right in and if
anything else comes up we will be sure
to go on a tangent so without further
ado it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
splendid spoon their meals are shipped
right to your door ready to eat and
you'll only lift a finger to press start
on your microwave they send delicious
plant-based meals and snacks right to
your door so it's ready to eat food that
is designed to fit into your busy
schedule instead of instead of taking
time out of it so we had really positive
experience with splendid spoon because
you know we keep kosher so plant-based
options actually really apply to us a
lot and the food was really delicious
and so easy to make like two things
about us like we are not gonna cook like
we are two girls who are not gonna cook
so they fit into our schedule really
nice every single meal from splendid
spoon is 100 plant-based it's
gluten-free and gmo free and they're
always made with plenty of veggies
legumes healthy fats whole grains and
spices from all over the world they also
have smoothies grain bowls soup bowls
and noodle bowls for you to discover
and with over 50 choices and a
constantly rotating menu there are
always new dishes to try i've personally
taken a liking to the noodle bowls
because i'm just like i said a noodle
girl one thing about me i am going to
eat the noodles try splendid spoon today
and take meal planning off your plate
just go to splendidaspoon.com
toast for 50 off your first box when you
subscribe to the breakfast lunch and
reset plan or the breakfast lunch and
dinner and reset plan that's
splendidspoon.com toast for 50 off when
you subscribe to the breakfast lunch and
reset plan or the breakfast lunch dinner
and reset plan splendidspoon.com
toast for 50 off
today's episode is also brought to you
by road derm which is a sponsor very
near and dear to my heart ever since i
bent over in a fire pit in utah and
burned all my lashes off because i do
love the look of false lashes they give
me more definition and drama but i find
them to be really tricky to apply the
lash glue gets really messy and it's
just too much of a hassle to be wearing
them every single day and that's why
we're excited about ro derm today's
sponsor because they offer a clinically
proven eyelash growth serum for people
who want thicker longer darker lashes
and if treatment is right for you you
can get it prescribed online the results
speak volumes in a 16 week clinical
trial eyelashes grew by 25 in length 106
in fullness and 18 in darkness to get
your prescription eyelash growth serum
all you have to do is complete a free
online visit and answer standard
questions about your eye health and
medical history after you submit your
information rohderm
a road term affiliated healthcare
provider will get back to you within 48
hours if prescribed your eyelash growth
serum will be delivered to your door
with free two-day shipping there's no
need for an in-person appointment and
you can always have the option to
message with your provider if you have
any questions whenever it's convenient
for you so right now if you're
prescribed new members will receive 10
off eyelash growth serum from row derm
when you go to rowderm.com forward slash
toast shipping is free you'll get free
and unlimited follow-ups with your
healthcare provider to support you
throughout your eyelash growth journey
rowderm
r-o-d-e-r-m dot com forward slash toast
great thank you so much for that it's a
pleasure
our first story more news is emerging
from the china verse kardashians tribe
it's wild courage
crazier and crazier corey granville
testified that he saw blackjack corey
rambolt yeah
i love you you don't know him no i do i
love love love love loves the best the
best she's my favorite kardashian 100
person
corey ramble to testify
that he saw blac chyna hit and whip rob
kardashian
corey claims he witnessed chyna punch
rob whip him with an iphone cord and
threatened to kill the reality tv star
during an explosive fight almost six
years ago chris's longtime boyfriend who
testified at the courthouse on tuesday
said it was just after daybreak on
december 15 2016 when he rushed to
kylie's house where robin chyna had been
staying and saw an altercation
when he walked into the home gamble says
he saw china standing by the bedroom
with a rod in her hand and rob about
seven feet away looking right in the
face and neck as if he had been in a
physical altercation corey said that
when chyna saw him enter the room she
immediately dropped the two or three
foot rod that was in her hand and
instead picked up a long phone cord that
was on the floor he said quote she
started whipping it at him she was
hitting rob and i got in the middle and
got hit too i had to try to get her
attention on me so rob could get his
belongings and get out of the house i
could smell the alcohol on her he added
that the house was a mess there were
christmas decorations littered on the
floor along with a broken gingerbread
house corey said that once rob was able
to get his wallet and keys from the
bedroom he walked out the front door and
tried to leave but cory's car was
blocking rob's car at that point an
enraged china allegedly picked up a
patio chair and hurled it at rob's car
china then continued to attack rob
corey claimed she jumped on the back of
him and punched him in the back of his
head she tried to get the small table to
throw it at him but rob was already in
his car
he said he stayed at the house for a few
minutes to make sure chyna wouldn't get
in her car and follow her
he said i asked her what she was going
on what was going on and she yelled that
she hated him she didn't like him she
said why would i like this fat [ __ ] if
he wasn't a part of this family oh my
god wait oh i'm literally gonna cry
that's literally the
that is like the saddest thing i've ever
heard in my life like i actually have
tears minds i didn't read that part
um i feel like for a long time like we
knew that robin chyna's relationship was
like obviously not a good one but this
has shed so much light on truly how
toxic it is and of course like you know
the trial is ongoing and you're innocent
until proven guilty but i do feel like
in this instance much like in the amber
heard johnny depp instance it's like
really this is the point of a trial so
that
everything comes to the truth can come
to light and i do feel like in as you
stated last week which now i agree with
because you've been sending me tick
tocks johnny depp like really is it yet
to be seen but he's really being
exonerated by what we're seeing by his
testimony and what's so crazy is his
testimony is over now so like the worst
like the part that would make him look
the worst is over because when you're on
trial like even if you're
you know innocent they're always going
to ask you questions to make you look
bad
so
now it's amber's turn so like
again i actually have come to the
conclusion that i think like they were
mutually abusive towards one another um
i i really don't know what to believe
but like i just think like what
we don't know like a fraction of
actually what went on in that
relationship yeah but his testimony was
actually really good for him i think
like in terms of the public discourse
but what i find so interesting about the
china
first of all i'm like just so tripped up
by that statement like at the end like
that really broke my heart um what's so
interesting is kim took the stand and
they were reading these emails she sent
to various executives at um
e about having you know china
having the show canceled so china is
suing them for having their show
canceled and there is proof that the
kardashians did that but what this trial
is for
is to prove what they had every reason
to so like it's not illegal what they
did because she was in a physically
abusive
person so everyone is like quaking
because they're like the kardashians are
gonna lose because all these emails that
are come out that chris and kim
personally wrote
yeah they did have a hand in taking the
show off the air but they are showing
the valid reasons in which they did that
right because china was abusive
crazy i think but this is like china's
lawsuit right but now they're
counter-suing
right and
so far she's coming off
worse than ever
she already was in a sympathetic
character and this
what's emerging and it's crazy how much
the kardashians actually protected her
yeah i know because we knew nothing we
knew nothing about this and they you
know and of course you know it streams
mom so they're really not good ever
going to speak on it if they don't have
to but she brought them to court so
right and and now we're seeing what
really happened and so they actually
showed a lot of restraint yeah and this
story while heartbreaking like does um
make me love corey so much that like he
went over there
put himself in harm's way so like
whenever anyone's in sort of sort of
emergency like
it's always like corey who runs over a
hundred percent cause he's like in a
weird way like a father figure even
though he's like the same age as
everyone but he's really like chris's
counterpart and like he went over there
put himself in the middle of like a
physical altercation to get rob out safe
so it just makes me love corey even more
yeah
very much so also very kind of kylie to
let them live in her house and trash it
yeah is that um is that like one of
obviously it wasn't the house like kylie
was living in it was like one of her
many properties perhaps or like her old
house it had before she sold it yeah but
also on this week's kardashians chloe
goes over to kylie's house to pick
something up but that's not kylie's new
house it's not like the big it's not the
one that's like very modern
yeah it's the one that's the farm
champion with like i loved that house
yeah yeah
oh yeah because they had that little
baby doll house yeah
unless she just hadn't moved yet but
that was so long ago no she hadn't moved
so i
but was kylie even there she was just
picking something up at kylie's house
right maybe rob lives there maybe
i mean i would love i've always said i
would love to see rob make a return to
the public life to the show
but
now like getting this inside scoop into
like what his life was like only a few
years ago i don't see him making a
return anytime soon like he's obviously
still
he's broken it's broken right
that was such a crazy time like the
robin china of it all yeah and like
we can't even really ever fully move
past it because they have a child
together so it's just like the craziest
it was the craziest time it was the
craziest time and i think you know he's
paying for it right like i think he
he got together with china not because
they were you know a great love no
because they had like mutual beef with
their family right
and i'm sure he's beyond remorseful and
like now how his family is out here like
protecting him so much like they really
are the definition of like family
forever even though like what rob did at
that time
was so egregious
they i don't think hold it against him i
think he feels bad enough yeah and he
suffered clearly clearly so crazy it's a
very interesting trial i don't think
blac chyna has taken the stand yet so
like i'm sure even more stuff is going
to come out when she does um and her mom
has quieted down which is good because
her mom was like out here on instagram
like threatening the judge and just like
being a little uh nuts on instagram live
right outside the courthouse and i
haven't heard about her in like a week
so hopefully um her lawyers like told
her to stop because it doesn't nothing
that her mom was doing was helping china
whatsoever yeah
so we'll keep you abreast on that
court um case so much legal news
recently so much legal news yeah but are
you ready for our next story little
movie news i think i am yeah the wicked
movie is getting split into two and
flams are flams are slamming it as a
money grab a hundred percent yeah the
future of wicked has changed but is it
for good oh that's good the director
john m two announced that his upcoming
film adaptation of the musical will be
split into two parts basically they said
as we tried to cut songs or trim
characters those decisions began to feel
like fatal compromises to the source
material that has entertained us all for
so many years like acting like this is
like a documentary right like people
have made plays into movies plenty of
times yes no but like wicked is like sp
and you know what like if they can do it
if they can do it on broadway in three
hours and they have to like change sets
and outfits you can edit a movie to two
hours yeah so
also what's so crazy about this is that
the first part is gonna be coming to us
december 2024
and um
they said it's successive christmas
holiday so it'd probably be december
2024 in december 2025. like and don't
ask me don't ask me to wait until 2025
for anything no and this movie not this
cast but the concept of the movie was
announced in 2017. yes it's literally
going to be a 10 year process like
better be good nothing is going to be
good enough
for that no
what's so funny is this has happened a
lot of times and where something is
taking like so long and people will find
like the old episode but like in 2025
someone's going to find this episode hi
2025 oh my god i hope you're happy
healthy
alive that would be great people have
found that before like we talked about a
movie
in like 2018 that was coming out in 2022
i'm really like that's never happening
right 2022 me i hope you're doing well i
hope you enjoy the movie
um and still those movies like haven't
come out like legally bond
totally we were talking about that in
the old studio
and this just is giving that vibe and by
the way it's not even going to be
december 2024 i'm calling it now because
like look at the downtown movie does
anybody want to talk about how they're
suppressing the downtown movies they're
suppressing the downtown it was supposed
to come out christmas 21 then it got
pushed back to march 22. now it's been
pushed back to may 22 and i'm sure if i
go check the instagram they've changed
the date again i wonder why why one why
are they suppressing the movie and two
where's henry talbot in the cast photo
is he not in the movie who's henry
talbot mary's husband oh henry yeah yeah
yeah uh he's not in the cast photo i
call him i call him you said henry
albert okay you just said like henry
talbot i thought that was the actor's
name i'm like who the [ __ ] is that
mary's husband isn't in the huge like
banner from real style you know you know
what movie we talked about i think maybe
even in the old studio that we just got
a snake preview of well that's our next
story barbie yep okay so back to uh
wicked i don't think movies need to be
two parts unless it's like a sequel and
no and we all know the story so it's not
like it's a spoiler and we're gonna wait
like from christmas to christmas this is
just this is just like the first piece
of information we've gotten about the
movie and it doesn't bode well
um i thought the casting was superior so
i don't know it's giving it's giving
cats
yeah
the musical it's off to a bad start i
mean it's actually like been off to a
bad start for a really long time because
the twitter account made to dedicated to
the movie was literally uh
made in 2016 like this has been
it's just kind of like a cursed project
i feel yeah but i don't want to be
negative because like when i hear
cynthia arrivo sing defying gravity like
i will have a stroke things will change
things will change for good
so like i really want to be optimistic
and excited but like
listen you have a while to become
optimistic
take your time that's true no rush
that's true okay our next story a little
more movie optimism margot robbie is
transforming into barbie in new promo
pics for the movie she's riding around
in a pink convertible i mean she's
literally barbie the highly anticipated
live-action film will be unboxed wow
mirror posted just with the punches
at movie theaters in july 2023
what
so why give us a picture because they
just want to keep dangling the
characters jackie the movie industry is
unwell and we keep chomping at the bit
we've been saying that for a really long
time they like have not recovered from
cobin i would say they're unhinged and
hella twisted
i would say the same i really would
so um
well it's interesting that we got to see
her because last we heard amy schumer
was going to be barbie yeah but then we
did hear it was margot yes
and
i'm curious what the storyline is going
to be because at one point it was gonna
be how barbie was like cast out of
barbie land yeah similar to elf which
sounds incredible but then they changed
it well because barbie cast out of
barbie land as amy schumer would be
so funny yeah um i don't know if margot
robbie's like a comedic actress i've
never seen her in anything particularly
funny so maybe now it's more of like a
traditional barbie story i don't know
yeah just like how barbie met ken right
how she has this like illustrious career
how she makes time for all of it right
so she really leans into her
relationship and being a working woman
and not having a working vagina yeah
that must complicate matters for ken
especially he doesn't have a working
penis either um she looks super cute but
again it's like how much fanfare can
there be for like this isn't the titanic
you know
so it's like with all these movies like
you know wicked actually might be the
new titanic like i could see there being
years of fanfare but years of fanfare
for barbie it just seems like a lot and
i don't really know what like the
studios are doing and we're just like so
thirsty that we are like talking
over this picture but at the end of the
day like it just looks like a teen vogue
photo shoot like it's really not giving
us anything and hot take like i don't
really understand why it needs to take
so long to make a movie
i agree like years look at siesta key
look at the key man look at keeping up
look at love island okay if love island
can turn around a premium like
jaw-dropping episode in 24 hours you can
make titanic in two months not titanic
because they actually like built the
ship yeah but barbie
you can make barbie in three weeks dead
ass like pharrell yeah who's playing ken
uh i don't know let's look at the imdb
for barbie but these projects that are
like so far away like their imdb's are
full of nothing oh you know like they
have no pictures yeah they would have
told us who was playing ken if there was
a ken to be played and if we're going
like the obvious route margot robbie for
barbie then ken has to be like shawn
mendes
you know ryan gosling like i said okay
actually this movie sounds awesome
i changed my mind
totally so yeah was he always going to
be ken i don't know but here's the
people who are in it will ferrell's in
it oh elf literally yeah yeah simulu
from selling sunset
literally america ferreira kate mckinnon
michael sarah slow down
i need to just like digest comedy yeah
kate mckinnon michael sarah alexandra
ship issa
actually sounds pretty good like yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'll keep waiting yeah
and i don't think ryan gosling gets out
of bed for a movie that's not going to
be awesome margot robbie yeah martial
robbie does not no she has yet to flop
she's yet to flop but you know what this
could be it speaking of flop have you
been following this viola davis story no
okay so viola davis there's a show on
showtime it's called like first lady
where they're focusing on three first
ladies i want to say it's betty ford
someone else that's played by julia
roberts it's michelle pfeiffer betty
ford julia roberts plays
let's say uh maybe barbara bush i don't
know and get up and viola davis plays
michelle obama okay
and
before the show premiered we got a
picture you know like that her portrait
you know michelle obama's portrait that
became like iconic
viola is in her michelle gear and she
looks just like she's like like the way
michelle's mouth moves like she looks
just like michelle obama so i think
people thought like this was going to be
the impersonation of a lifetime and i've
seen a few clips on tick tock and like
it's it's really bad like she's so over
acting out yes
she's so overacting and i guess i never
realized like michelle obama like her
upper lip goes up when she talks i never
noticed it and now like it became like
viola's way of impersonating and it's
like
it's so unflattering and it's really bad
acting and so much so that viola davis
had to address it she was like all right
not every you know project you're gonna
do your you do
is gonna be great like you are gonna
fail sometimes like she admitted and i
thought it was so crazy because it's
like viola davis never flopped a day in
her life right she's literally oscar
oscar oscar golden globe golden globe
oscar um and it's like this crazy thing
that's come out of this random tv show
but is the show good haven't heard of
acting's bad i haven't heard a thing
yeah and also the third first lady is
eleanor roosevelt by julia roberts
jillian anderson sure i could have sworn
it was julia roberts no she's nowhere
near the project and michelle pfeiffer
is betty ford yes she was giving january
jones um in mad men when i saw the
trailer so it sounds like an interesting
concept for a show
but there's just now been like a lot of
discourse around biola david's
performance because when you were just
saying she's never flopped it reminded
me of viola davis who up until recently
had never flopped wow but you know what
like we all have bad days at work
normal lies doing a bad job at work
seriously
well are you ready for our next story
someone who's doing a great job at work
is it me with these ads yes and bad baby
oh love that for her today's episode is
brought to you by wonderskin we're gonna
tell you about a beauty brand that we're
obsessed with taking over our beauty
counters all over tik tok all over
social media and they're winning awards
everywhere the brand is wonderskin and
this is a brand you've got to check out
so you've probably seen videos of their
peel and reveal lip stain i've seen them
all over tik tok it's the coolest lip
product i've ever used you put on a like
it's like a bright electric blue lip
mask um spray it with their activator
and in seconds you peel off the mask and
reveal a lip color that is transfer
proof waterproof and it will last for 10
hours it's like a really pretty lip
stain
also that product won the allure best of
beauty breakthrough award but they
didn't stop there they have the best
skin care it's called purevox which is
cover-up spelled backwards because it's
literally the opposite of covering up
they are three products that work
together to give you flawless looking
skin with a beautiful glow and you'll
see results after the first time you see
it and meaningful results in just four
weeks for the first time in years i can
leave my house confidently without any
cover-up makeup on it's just the pure
box skincare wonderskin was on the today
show they've been in people magazine um
and they have their cult favorite called
liquid gym which is a serum that helps
sculpt your jawline your cheekbones and
your neck in as little as two weeks so
we've been using wonderskin products for
a while now and as we said we're
obsessed they create products unlike
anything we've ever tried before and the
best part is they all work and i've made
a difference in both my makeup and my
skincare routine so right now if you go
to wonderskin.com and use the promo code
toast you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping on orders of over 50
that's 20 off when you go to
wonderskin.com and use our promo code
toast thank you claudia you love your
pure rock i really do
bad baby posts a receipt to prove her 50
million dollar only fans earnings in one
year truly cash her outside bad baby po
new york post strikes again killing it
bad baby posted a screenshot of a
receipt along with a screen recording of
her pulling up the receipt so you know
it's real via instagram on monday to
prove she's made 50 million dollars from
only fans she said go cry about it [ __ ]
she wrote in her caption adding that she
couldn't have done it without the
support of the scoop agency partners the
rashi the receipt shows that the once
troubled teen born danielle bregoli has
earned early nearly 53 million dollars
in gross profits with her net landing
her closer to 42 million after taxes 20
million and then the cut to scoop agency
partners and then she just bought the 15
million home it's 15 million i can't
remember six million dollars yeah it was
six or 15 i was just uh
i you said six i did and then when i was
telling you six before it seemed low can
we look up how much her house cost um
but this is just an update to a story me
and ben were talking about last week
because we were so confused how the bad
baby girl bought a house in boca for
what i believe was
6.1 million dollars thank you confirmed
it's a gorgeous house gorgeous
yeah no it's not the vibe that i would
have expected from boca from bad from
bad herself baby comma bad
so
we were shook because we were trying to
moder and a little too modern for my
taste very fortress
oh yes we were trying to like figure out
all her her revenue streams like she
does music she owns this like small
record label so we were like coming up
with the receipts for how you still buy
a six million dollar house and we had
totally forgotten that she had announced
that she was joining joining only fans
like a year ago and the day she
announced she like broke all sorts of
records yeah she made a million dollars
in six hours so i had totally forgotten
about that now knowing she made 52 and
she only bought a six million dollar
house i'm very proud of her for being
fiscally responsible because you know
what you get a six million dollar house
when you put down like a million bucks i
don't know how houses work but it
depends what kind of mortgage you want
yeah like 30-year fixed but i would say
at least 20
which is 20 of 6.
that's a great question yeah a fifth of
a sixth
i think it's like 1.5
that's
1.2 i'm literally like a mathematician
yeah no albert einstein over here
literally um
so i just wanted to update everyone
everyone was sending me like when me and
ben were like sitting here for hours
puzzled like how does she have so much
money everyone's like screaming only
fans so i know that but me and ben were
also quaking because
the decision to choose to live in boca
like is a unique one it's not you know
it's what i think of it's not twisted or
unhinged but it is therefore it is
unique um and it's just not what i think
of when i think of places bad babies
should live
so um we were joking that it sounds like
she's like an old jewish woman and
thanks to some toasters digging deep
into her ancestry bahad bahabi's father
is jewish
bahad when you say it like that she
sounds jewish yeah like from the great
family of bahabi the hobbies were huge
in the shtetl the hobbies were
huge in the shuttle like beyond huge
tevye the hobby
the fiddler on the roof saga you didn't
know you needed
um so like really happy for bahad we'd
love to see women in business for sure i
have a newfound respect i mean i'm not
the hots demo i don't think she thinks
that i am um but i'd love to see a
working woman an industrious
self-starter such as she plus
plenty of people have gone viral for
doing this yeah that and to get your
start on dr phil
and to come away
with that minimum 50 million plus she
has like sponsorship deals she has her
music so this is like just one source of
income you got to give it up for bob i
completely agree everyone is it was
against her and everyone said that you
know she could never do it it's true and
you know what she said she said cash me
outside
how about that
and then she said [ __ ] around and find
out she said i'm the hot bahabi
and jackie first of all that was the
funniest thing you've ever said um
second of all i completely agree like
everyone counted out the countess
[Laughter]
and now we and you know what now people
are like i love when people show
screenshots of their only fans because
it's like real true like you want to
talk the talk walk the walk show me your
[ __ ] only fans so now everyone's like
do larsa next do larson eggs
i would love for people to start sharing
even though like you know i actually
would love to talk to you about this
especially on tick tock there's like
this whole conversation about around
financial transparency like if you're an
influencer like it's people are so like
commend you for sharing how much money
you make and like being transparent
about deals you get or whatever but it's
like and and maybe it's just me being
old school but like isn't that private
yeah so there are some things that you
know everything's always changing in
life in society but i think it will
always be pretty tacky to talk about
money yeah um i agree and find with
financial transparency like in the
corporate world corporate world for sure
because everyone you know goes into
their negotiations like really siloed
and only like knowing what they know and
they don't know what the person who's
doing the same work the same work maybe
even less than is making but they just
ask for it themselves and sometimes you
need that confidence to like to know
that your partner has as making ten
thousand more you can go in and ask for
ten thousand you need context yeah for
sure but i think like this expectation
that every and you should share that
like with your co-workers perhaps and
there needs to be some better way of
doing it yeah and the fact that you
can't share how much money you make in a
corporate space without it being an hr
violation is actually like really [ __ ]
up but that doesn't mean that you need
to like go around to the rest of the
world and share how much money you make
yeah no this whole like financial
transparency thing on tick tock like
like applauding content creators who
like share exactly how much money they
make every month i just don't feel like
i'm ever going to do that it's
definitely extremely interesting and i
will consume anyone who wants to wonder
what they make um but i don't think it's
a requirement agreed and
if you just like anything else if
someone wants to do it and someone that
doesn't want to do it growth live your
best lives doing it or not doing it yeah
but i think also in the influencer space
it's a little um helpful when you have
like managers and agents because they
have the track the content you know what
everybody else is making you know what
you're worth yep totally so that should
be
right
helpful enough yeah but no i'm so
curious if anybody like wants to share
what they're making yeah i'd love to
hear how much money people make yeah
how much money did you make
i'm kidding i already know um i was
going to say one more thing about this
only fans thing uh you think how much
money do you think larson makes ten
thousand dollars a day oh right what
does that equal out to a year 365 times
ten thousand add two twos 36 million 3.6
oh
that makes sense my mathematician if
that is making 50 and lars is making 3.6
i believe that i believe
um i was going to say one more thing and
you just keep sidetracking i'm so sorry
i'll give you a few minutes to yourself
no i remembered it and then you took it
away again [ __ ] i'm so sorry
i was trying to like speak so that you
could have a moment to think i wasn't
trying to snatch the more you speak okay
sorry the less i can do the more you say
the less i know ever you straight what i
was gonna say
i'm sure like when she bought this house
i feel like you obviously forgot that
about the only fence things but i think
that like we're always
people are always living above their
means it's like they scrape together
everything to buy a house that they
really couldn't afford so
i i guess i really have no point in what
i'm saying i'm so glad we waited for you
i usually like when influencers are
buying houses it's like they bought you
know they're not saving they're not
being yeah
conservative conservatives and i'm glad
to see that she is but i would have
assumed the same as you that like she
bought the biggest house that she could
right so if she made 50 million dollars
let's say she realistically maybe took
home 20. um and then a six million
dollar house where you put 20 percent
down assuming she didn't pay all cash um
i think that's very responsible and i'm
very the more we talk about it more
respect i'm having for bahad i if any
today's episode has done anything like i
went from really not having an opinion
to having a ton of respect i think you
went from thinking that bahad was
twisted unique and um unhinged to
actually thinking she's quite hinged
quite quite
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
because the toast is making news oh yeah
cause it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
okay our fifth and final story the toast
is making news because stassi came on
the morning toast yesterday and shared a
bit of tea that like had me quaking and
i want to discuss with you she said that
the vanderpump rules spin-off was in the
works before she was fired
sassy claimed a vanderpump world
spin-off tentatively titled valley rules
was in the works before bravo fired her
in june 2020. she said that her wedding
to bow was intended to be the
transitional episode between both shows
if you listen to the show you've heard
all of this why am i recounting it right
so with statsy's episode i asked her i'm
like what is the juiciest thing in this
book like let's
let's talk about like the real like the
things people want to know like juicy
gossip and
she said that
in the same way that we were introduced
to vanderpump rules at like the 59th
minute of the real housewives of beverly
hills and we transitioned like sheena in
the restaurant they were planning on
doing that at her wedding having her
wedding be like the last few final
minutes of vanderpump rules and then the
rest of the cast flies home and suddenly
we're in a new show called valley rules
all of the older castmates tom ariana
tom katie stassi most of them live in
the valley so they were gonna have their
own show that's no longer tied to the
restaurant which made a lot of sense
because for years it's actually made no
sense no and like fans have been saying
this for so long like there needs to be
two shows like the juniors and the
seniors freshmen like upperclassmen so
the freshmen were still gonna be at sir
new
the charlies maybe new people new
servers who are new to reality tv who
still actually work at the restaurant
and who have nothing to lose and can be
unhinged and um we're probably single
and yeah we'll give us all of that fair
yeah but our faves we would watch on a
different show which is a solution we've
all been you know waiting for for a long
time
and it's crazy that actually bravo had
the same idea and valley rules is an
incredibly cute name and it's such a
shame that it's not happening i know
that it didn't well half the fact cass
got fired right
but i do feel like they're all still
friends like the show still writes
itself yes
like now that she's a mom right she
doesn't think she would ever do
reality tv again because like it's one
thing that she signed up for but she i
couldn't really imagine a world in which
someone else is in charge of like
editing and then putting out content
that includes her daughter which i think
a lot of and lala might feel that way um
sheena might feel that white britney
might feel that way yeah so i think like
it's over like the idea i don't think it
ever would happen but it was a great
idea and i think that might have
inspired bravo's decision to do the two
new york shows
even though i don't think it works the
same i'm still curious about it and i'm
here for it i'm gonna keep an open mind
about it it's just i know this probably
like is you know so in the graveyard at
bravo but for us this is like new
information
and um i don't want to like hope for
anything but it really did sound like a
good show and like now people are
pulling this clip of andy like
accidentally saying valley rules on
watch evans live the other night and
people were so confused and now it all
makes sense because the toast is making
things makes sense making things make
sense so that was really fun um to hear
and see yeah um
and now we can just keep going into our
tv recap oh yeah perfect so we are going
to discuss the summer house
season finale i might have dropped one
card and of course is it the card that i
need yeah okay hold on
you got it okay
um
summer house not nazi's finale actually
there's one more episode and the uh
real hot size of new jersey season
finale which wrapped up in nashville
which i thought was weird like to end on
a trip i hadn't heard that before um
and that tv recap is brought to you by
air doctor the weather's finally warming
up spring is in the air and so is pollen
so if you have allergies you already
know what we're talking about
fortunately you don't have to suffer
because a high quality air purifier is
key to surviving spring allergies air
doctor captures a wide range of
pollutants including odors gases and
chemicals like formaldehyde from stinky
gym clothes to chemical cleaning
products air doctor is always on call to
keep your air fresh and clean
their classic purifier is powerful
enough to circulate the air in a 330
plus square foot room four times per
hour so we're spending 90 percent of our
time indoors as americans according to
the epa and
indoor air can actually be two to five
times more polluted than outdoor air so
if you think you're safe inside from
allergies you're not and you better be
purifying your home with an air doctor
purifier we have one at the studio and
we have one at the house and i'm not
gonna lie i was like kind of skeptical
about
like air purifiers i just thought it was
every they're everything i know i
thought it was like kind of like
boo hooky but
honestly hogwash because ben suffers
from allergies and i don't i'm like
you're fine i've never slept better and
when i wake up i just wake up with a dry
throat and nose air purifier is just
everything you need within a few days of
getting air doctor me and ben's nasal
congestion coughing sneezing itchy nose
and watery eyes we're gone and we're
sleeping so much better super easy to
set up it arrives in the mail a
professional quality hepa air purifier
is recommended by leading medical
experts as an effective way to reduce
seasonal allergies airborne germs and
viruses to protect your home
make sure you get an air doctor to keep
you and your family safe air doctor
comes with no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantee so if you don't
love it just send it back for a refund
minus shipping just go to
airdoctorpro.com and use the promo code
toast you'll receive a 35 off discount
on their classic air doctor 3000
purifier 35 off but only if you go to
a-i-r-d-o-c-t-o-r-p-r-o
dot com use the promo code toast i love
mine so much and i also just want to
give a plug if you are experiencing um
pregnancy or just any sort of nausea
um like for me i couldn't take the smell
of my kitchen i put an air doctor right
outside my kitchen and it really really
helped smart really helped okay let's
start with summer house it was prom and
craig surprise paige and honestly like
i've never
like screamed so loud and then when she
came down for like her dress reveal of
course like paige could just like borrow
one of her friend's dress and end up
looking like so [ __ ] stunning it's
not even fair um the way like i
seriously would take ebola for paige and
craig i'm obsessed no this was me when
craig arrived
okay and this was me when she came down
in her
literally obsessed yeah i don't even
know what happened in the rest episode i
could not care less it was paige and
craig yeah what happened the florist the
fight at the restaurant did yell of
course always danielle running after
kyle there's something weird there i
didn't understand the fight like is the
whole house in the tizzy because kyle
and amanda were fighting like no the
roller house was in a tizzy because he
like slammed his hands on the table and
said no one like understands what he's
going through like he's the only one who
has a stressful job or a stressful life
and they're like please and then amanda
was embarrassed that he acted that way
that he slammed his hands on the table
and it's like being drunk and like
everyone's just trying to have a nice
night yeah and amanda's just like
[ __ ] done with him yeah which is just
so weird and she's about to get started
with it right because i totally
understand her feelings but like you are
getting married and you still could make
a choice a different choice but i'm sure
that the show like highlights the worst
of their relationship especially because
it seems like a lot of their
relationship they are at their worst
when they're like drinking and out and
that's the show i'm sure during the week
when they're like sitting on the couch
and now they have all these new dogs
have you seen like they're foster dogs
you know yeah totally um
but i do believe this is like the last
episode we'll get in the house because
next week is the wedding yeah which is
cool that they are the wedding looks
amazing what a backyard stunning home
need more details on the estate i'm sure
we will get some next week yeah i think
the prenup stuff is like super
interesting because
there's literally um
no way amanda should sign that i cannot
believe amanda doesn't own any part of
the company right in act like on paper
right and if they do split up she should
get some of the company so obviously the
shouldn't be like
kyle's percentage is his it's like if we
split up you get this much as opposed to
half it's so selfish i'm sure that's
what kyle's plan is but she should get
half
literally she's like the face of the
brand yeah and she's on
the show hawking it just as much as he
is and he does she does the graphic
design like she designed all the cameras
right i think she does a lot of the
social media like she does plenty yeah
and she just she just doesn't talk about
it every five seconds like kyle does
right because you can have a job and
spoiler alert not talk about it and you
can flop at it you can normalize
flopping at it um so once in a while
when getting yourself fired we also saw
like the beginning stages of carl and
lindsey which was actually really cute
because lindsay has been like really um
kind of chaotic this summer and knowing
what we know now that they're in like
the most stable happy relationship like
it actually is really cute i saw
something like in the middle of the
night i think it was a dm like i can't
remember where i saw it that crap or
maybe like i dreamt it but someone i
think dm me that craig said a pillows
and beer live that their relationship is
fake
can't recall where i saw it because um
i had a rough night
let me go through my dms wait that's so
crazy
like
i mean
no i like literally can't understand why
it would be fake because it's actually
so cute
i know
i believe you you don't have to search
for it like i really believe you unless
you think it was truly a dream no i
don't think it was a dream that would be
like a really weird thing to dream about
but i also can't find it i've been
dreaming about such weird things
um
[Music]
okay and then what else happened oh i
wanted to talk about maya and oliver
like maya setting him up not to come
dressed up he's like
actually mean because he was like no one
told me to dress up and she was like
actually he could wear whatever he wants
like don't be mean to him about what
he's wearing like it's a problem he he
should know the the attire yeah but also
everyone there like the the thousands of
people that they invite also weren't
dressed up yeah but he was like a date
and why wasn't he there for pictures um
i don't know i don't know either and
then like alex and sierra like him prom
posing so pathetic
um and i've also like started to turn on
maya and i need to see how she acts at
the reunion but i just like had such a
bad taste in my mouth watching her on
this episode of watch it happens live
cause like
when i now when i watch the episode i
see how good of a friend paige and
sierra were to her like really included
like they're a duo paige and sierra
sierra
paige and sierra are like this dynamic
duo they don't need anyone else they
drive out with her they take care of her
she lays in the bed with them like she
was such a good they were such good
friends to her and she so changed her
tune on watch robin's live which i
thought was just like kind of a shitty
thing to do and if she has that vibe at
the reunion like i will be turned on her
that bed needs to be in the bravo
hall of fame that bed needs to be
what's the word i'm looking for
like the gray garden's house it was
with a d
like when something's really dirty like
you just
come on help with the word when
something's really dirty yeah it's like
it's like when something's unlivable
condensed
yes thank you queen there is a d in
damned
the bed needs to be condemned like them
spilling drinking in their outside
clothes then sleeping in there like i
could die in mama the outside clothes
inside the bed yeah the soda cans and
everyone like maya gets in the bed
amanda gets in the bed bathing suits
lindsay and danielle never get in the
bed it's crazy i like that lindsey and
danielle are like
so separate yeah
i wouldn't get in the bed um i would
just because i'm obsessed with paige and
sierra i always sit at the foot of the
bed but the idea of like lying and also
like then if you're in the middle you
have to look left and right that's the
worst people that's the source i don't
like that i agree i like to look at you
straight on yeah um
so it was like a fine episode um but the
paige and craig have it all made it like
like the best episode i've ever seen of
television yeah i that was like really
they surprised me no i know and she was
so surprised too oh my truly and
i was actually talking to paige and she
like sent me some um
some like behind the scenes footage of
like when she was actually surprised and
she like literally you never saw someone
so surprised in your whole life that's
really cute i have to say as much as
i've hated like loathed entirely doing
the show without you even though i love
the co-host there's just like nothing
better than us um i will say that having
to reach out to all these people has
been so good for my social life that's
what i was saying to you you've made so
many friends like me and chad and ford
like i just bought a purse off of
shannon ford like i'm obsessed with
shannon ford she was like getting rid of
this celine bag and i was like i'll take
it um i text with paige like i really
want to thank you because like you know
the thirst monster in me is very
appreciative for all the new famous
friends i have yeah no one before you
had to do all that outreach you were so
shy so you never have reached out to
those people unless you had a reason to
so i'm glad that it's forced you to come
out of your shell you know me like
always just doubting myself yeah i've
spoken so true a little awkward that's
me
um okay let's talk about the real
housewives of new jersey the season
finale was
so good even though i felt like they
spent a lot of time in the episode like
talking about stuff and then when it
actually came down to the teresa and
margaret conversation
they kind of abruptly ended it like
suddenly margaret was standing like it
escalated so quickly it was going in a
really positive direction and then it
turned and i'm sorry i am so with team
margaret and i don't know how anyone
else is not like it's true the way the
women have such a low bar for theresa
like even her brother being like it's a
big step she came and gave the worst
half-assed apology on the planet and
everyone's like isn't that nice like
she's literally a toddler yeah and um i
love that margaret doesn't stand for
that like she's gonna have the same
standard for her best friend jackie
goldschneider her best friend melissa
her the girloris as she's gonna have for
teresa because we are all equal yeah i
agree and i also love that like margaret
does have a soft space in her heart she
does it's not like she just has a hard
on for her like you know because she can
be really frustrating like there is love
there and there is something to return
to but margaret's not going to be
treated the way that theresa treats
people no end you know what i had
literally forgotten about it's just hair
pulling the hair pulling i never forgot
and the way margaret forgave her so
quickly large never forgot no but she
did she forget she let it go she forgave
but she did not forget 100 so it's just
like after all this time why the [ __ ]
would margaret want to be friends with
um theresa and you know jackie's being a
really good friend to margaret and i
know why and i get it but like it is
beyond frustrating to watch melissa and
i was talking to you about this before
like melissa has gotten herself into a
place where she's so um
is the word ambivalent
like middle ground yeah she's so
ambivalent that she actually doesn't
have a role in the group really and i
actually i i don't think it could happen
because i think joe gorga adds too much
to the show but she actually is in the
perfect position to be a friend of like
i think tracy has added more to the plot
than melissa just because melissa is so
afraid of offending her sister-in-law
she can't she can't well it looks like
things changed at the reunion maybe
because i think that teresa like
this is joe like comes for joe and it's
like oh you want to come for me now i
can unleash all the things i was holding
back in order to protect you and melissa
is in an impossible situation and i
don't think she would ever be friends
because when i look i think that andy
and like bravo loves the familial aspect
the husband the fact that like like
theresa and margaret could never speak
again you know there was an offense and
we could never speak again there's
really nothing tying us together but
like melissa and teresa will always have
to come back to each other and that is
good for television yeah as opposed to
like okay i'll film with this person
who's my co-worker but i never care less
this doesn't affect my life i thought
the scene in the kitchen i was actually
really proud of margaret for literally
calling every [ __ ] woman out and
being like she literally called me fat
and you guys did nothing and you're
sitting here being like who's her
apologies so great like margaret was on
the verge of tears like after all the
things that she said about margaret and
then in front of the entire group she's
like well margaret never forgets to eat
like so nasty and you know what like
really dolores like you that that's who
you're gonna stand by like i can
understand jennifer being so blindly
loyal and dolores is blindly loyal to a
degree but doris has a a moral compass
like she really does and for all those
women to sit there and say nothing like
i was with margaret like what the [ __ ]
you guys seriously i actually really
like um tracy me too i she doesn't like
add a ton but she's also not full-time
so it's not but she's on the right side
of history she's on the right side of
history i think she brings a fun element
like she's always with the girlies and
tiki like the boys love tiki and zach
like having to pop him i was watching
and he was like
who's with tiki barber i was like
his wife you know the show ben little
there's something for everyone so
impressed yeah no i was impressed to be
watching something of such caliber let's
talk about louie of it all because i
feel like at the end of the episode like
we saw like a unique
perspective let's go back to our fifty
thousand dollar house
no that's not
fifty thousand square foot house even
though i think it's 15 and he was like
mumbling over his words because on what
happens live andy said 15. oh well he
said 50. i heard 50. he obviously said
50. there were so many like crazy
[ __ ] things when he called his
ex-girlfriends
sick desperate low lives i was like okay
you're the low life obviously like no
but okay say they were all sick
desperate low lives what does that say
about you right who are you attracted to
just got roped into one accidentally
like you have low life after the other
after the other
100 for being drawn to low lives he is
such a low life that's a perfect word
and when he got like a little too angry
at the end and he was like come on
teresa it's so clear margaret wants to
sit in your throne or something like
that i'm like oh please margaret wants
to be here yeah it's like
that's the last thing theresa needs
someone who gasses her up even more
delusion i know at first for a while i
was like maybe when they go back to the
hotel he knocked some sense into her
because when when they come back from
being alone in the beginning she's
always pretty okay she said hi to
margaret but then of course she gets
back to her old self i thought he was
taking her back to the hotel and like
really like
like supporting her in public
you know correcting her in private yes i
agree but he's gassing her up even more
even when she was like acting out it's
not like he was gassing her up while he
was she was acting out he's like tree
like that's a lot this is a big reaction
so i thought maybe he was studying her
but i think he's just fanning the flames
yeah and
i have no idea what goes on but they are
like engaged i don't think this they're
getting married is
no i think they're full steam ahead and
i think theresa will
maybe end up in a similar place that she
was with joe in the sense of like not
being in the happiest marriage but
so stubborn that she'll stay in it
yeah but like i mean say i don't know
the exact allegations against louie i
only really know what has been brought
on the show um
so say like a lot of that is true but i
do feel like louie really wants this
relationship to work to work like
i don't think people who are abusive
just stop being abusive no i know and
maybe he'll just act his way through it
and you know what you remember last
season when marge opened up about um
being sexually assaulted in the
workplace and theresa said it could
never happen to her because she's too
weak that was the most that because
she's too strong yeah yeah she never let
it happen to her it could never happen
to her because she's theresa that was
like
one of the most [ __ ] up things i think
i've ever heard being said right and and
so it tracks that she's not even going
to address what's being said about her
boyfriend there are so many like
awful things that she said and they just
get no
yeah anything like even two weeks ago
calling her ass jiggly like is that what
happened on another show with a
housewife who was like in a
a different position
that's like a fireable offense not a
fireable offense but like all the women
would be like oh yeah and the person
would be like i don't stand by my
actions right like a statement yeah so
it's just [ __ ] like the show is so
good but it's also so frustrating like
as someone who like i watch these shows
and i'm just like a person with a heart
you know and i just can't believe there
are people out there teresa stands out
there like i would love to interview one
of them and be like are you okay they
have to be joking no no it's like
a funny position to take like we're
gonna defend tree no matter what i don't
think i could like if you paid me six
million dollars and be like come up with
a really good defense for tree i like i
literally don't think i could no but the
best defense that i'd heard so far was
dolores comparing her to like a puppy in
the shelter yeah but we've been saying
that literally for six seasons it was
always like she's in a bad marriage oh
she just she's going to jail oh she just
got out of jail oh joe's in jail oh
joe's dealing with a lot now joe's
getting divorced it can't always be
something like who like you at some
point where's your personal
accountability yeah we all have a lot of
[ __ ] going on in our lives yeah no and i
think the the most
glaring part is like
what she so she wants to protect louie
like at all costs and because she's like
this dog in the shelter and that i can
delores made me see it that's right but
like what about when you make up rumors
about jackie and then go so hard at
margaret for saying truths about
jennifer like why are
how you can't see that that's what
really frustrates me about her as a cast
member yep and i'm putting like the same
amount of pressure on andy that i put on
him on candace first monique to like
really make
teresa see how like what she did last
season was
so [ __ ] up and she thinks what
margaret's doing is [ __ ] up wait till
theresa hears about what she did last
season like if andy doesn't
drill that home like i will be so and i
know there's no getting through to trump
i mean he once said it he said it on
watch what happens live this season like
do you see how this equals x squared
carry the one and she was like no it's
different because um that wasn't true
therefore making it worse actually
theresa but thank you for bringing that
up
um so i'm really looking forward to
really
explaining trailer was two minutes long
joe gorga walks off
jennifer calls dolores the c word
there's fighting on both couches like
it's very interesting yes and i just
want to end on a positive which was that
chicken eating contest was so funny i'm
back to loving billy the men of new
jersey
make the show make and they know that
and the women know that and i i'm sure
it's like more fun for everyone like we
want to see your husbands we want them
to go on the trips like right when we
were last time beverly hills women took
their husbands on the trip literally
like back when ken was when they were
dean stupid yeah yeah so it's a joy to
watch like great happy couples and it
really we don't get it on even though
it's the housewives franchise we don't
get it anywhere else no i completely
agree the chicken eating was amazing i
was loving billy and jennifer was being
a little annoying but like she was being
hysterical and bill won by a mile a
hundred percent joe workers like a
little annoying with all the competition
stuff but he keeps the group the group
going 100 he's the fun man but my heart
permanently belongs to frank catania and
joe benigno frank catania is my
celebrity crush i completely look at me
i completely agree like
i
would take a bullet for him but also
evan
so hot and just like good advice good
time great husband very nice looking
good husband good dad like he's a real
catcher they all are catches i could
make i could actually make the case bill
aiden crush
joe benigno i um and joe gorga
i saw evan goldschnider a couple weeks
ago when he gave me a hug and like
honestly like it was like one of the
best hugs of my life he's
so hot i'm sure that like he gets kind
of slept on
100 because he's not like joe gorga so
out there like putting dildos in his
mouth he's just like a guy yeah he's
just a guy he's always wearing a hat you
know he's not really he's just doing his
own thing
but i'm sure in person he could be a
presence for sure a force it's
overwhelming like the height the smell
like he's really like a gorgeous man but
not a force like frank catania no
there's no force like frankentonia i
seriously like if i was sleeping next to
frankentania every night like do you
know how safe i would feel
like emotionally physically like he is
just not emotionally because he's
probably cheating on you know when
jennifer was like what kind of massage
parlors did you own he's like good ones
i was crying i love him dolores like
delores is dating someone new morris has
the best of both worlds because she gets
to sleep in the same house as frank
italian so you have that security but
you're not really emotionally on him to
fill your left hand 100
um so next week is reunion it should be
very really good it's three parts it
better be it better be and that is our
show right our show we're about to film
something really fun exciting and
special and for our patreon channel i
guess i could just tell everyone
you know because like why do we have to
you know bury the lead
i'm going to be trying spritz for the
first time we are recording my
first impressions of trying speak
sessions yes that's going to be our
third episode for the month of january
april on patreon right now so head over
to patreon.com
morning toast not just anything not just
heading no don't go to patreon.com
yikes thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast of the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the festive stories that you need to
know everybody through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please don't forget to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available to podcast anywhere podcasts
we found out spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i heard you catbox all the
places so whenever you listen to the
podcast find out more until sleep if i
start you better beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye